[Musik]
der krise aska zahl im kopf ist ein oder
mächtigsten männer in kirgistan
ihm gehört der größte markt
zentralasiens der kirgisische dort
neumarkt bei bischkek
das ist ein typischer kirgisischer
filzhut denn lasse ich ihnen als
geschenk wir sind bisher von venedig
nach istanbul durch die türkei durch den
kaukasus doch kasachstan und usbekistan
bis in die griechische stadt osch
gereist von roche aus haben wir nun die
kirgisische hauptstadt bischkek gereicht
wir sind auf dem nordmarkt der markt
gehört dem kirgisischen geschäftsmann
zahl im bk sein basa gehöre zu den
weltweit zehn größten märkten erklärt er
15.000 händler werden hinter ihren
stätten um käufer alles ist hier zu
haben
lederwaren aus pakistan billig spielzeug
oder fernsehgeräte aus china teppiche
aus der türkei das ist die beliebteste
und schönste straße in bischkek die
lederstraße sie führt von hier quer
durch den markt direkt nach kasachstan
das nur 20 kilometer von hier entfernt
liegt es heißt ja auch hier in kirgistan
seien vor allem die usbeken die guten
händler die krisen seien nur maden die
partie finden und wir wissen
mittlerweile besser gelernt selbst
handel zu treiben
ja in anderen ländern in russland
kasachstan gibt es immer mehr genießen
die dort geschäfte früher haben sie
darauf gewartet bis ihn ein gitter onkel
eine tante in der regierung half jetzt
haben sie ihr lernt für sich selbst zu
sorgen
man hat ihnen am guten gegeben jetzt
fangen sie ihre fische selbst die
meisten waren die hier auf dem
skateboard neumarkt angeboten werden
kommen aus china
und die chinesischen händler sie
verständigen sich mit ein paar brocken
russisch oder chinesisch
heimelektronik japanischer marken aus
china
höchstwahrscheinlich fälschung
das angebot ist überwältigend
das ist ein dvd player aus chinesischer
produktion
er kostet nur gerade 25 dollar der dort
heumarkt bei die piquets die
handelsdrehscheibe doti vor allem
chinesische billig waren die
zentralasiatischen länder nach russland
der brauch nach westeuropa gelangen
die sowjetunion gab es nicht mehr
und die chinesen unsere großen nachbarn
wollten sich bei uns immer mehr
ausbreiten
das wollten wir so nicht wir haben dann
mit diesem markt unsere eigene
kirgisische handels brücke geschaffen
welche china mit den anderen
zentralasiatischen staaten und mit
russland verbindet war dem kopf hat den
neunziger jahren mit einem ersten
container den grundstein für diesen
markt gelegt heute ist der einer der
mächtigsten männer in land und falls
einmal probleme bekommen sollte hat er
vorgesorgt als honorarkonsul von
brasilien genießt der nämlichen
kirgistan diplomatische immunität
ich krieg die hauptstadt kirgistans
die symbolik der macht erinnert an die
sowjetische vergangenheit
hier dominiert militärisches premium
trotz verschiedener reform im frühjahr
2010 wurde das letzte autoritäre regime
gestürzt und das land wandte sich einer
parlamentarischen demokratie zu auf
diesen moment hatte ich mich lange
gefreut ich bin unterwegs zu hellen
denen dieses kampfes um mehr demokratie
in kirgistan zur damaligen
übergangspräsidentin rosa otunbajewa
sie fühle sich heute leider unwohl werde
sich deshalb nur ganz kurz zeit für uns
nehmen können hieß es zuerst an der
pforte rosa otunbajewa erklärt mir
weshalb die von ihr angestoßenen
politischen reformen bei den kirgisen
sofort anklang gefunden hätten
wir sind vom nomadentum geprägt und
haben ein ausgeprägtes
gerechtigkeitsgefühl lieber verlassen
wir unser dorf wenn wir dort nicht zu
unserer meinung stehen kann
dieser sinn für gerechtigkeit trägt dazu
bei dass unser volk eines autoritären
druck aushält
die kirgisen dulden es nicht wenn das
allgemeingut nur einer familie einem
klenk und alle möchten dass die
lebensbedingungen in unserem schönen
land immer besser werden ihre
nachbarländer im spec stern kasachstan
braucht durch wenigsten oder
aserbaidschan werden sehr autoritär
regiert denken sie das ist dort seinem
arabischen frühling kommen könnte all
unsere nachbarn ergreifen im moment
maßnahmen mit denen die sogenannte
stabilität gestärkt werden soll
das internet wird kontrolliert mit neuen
gesetzen werden die einnahmen von
wohltätigen organisationen und parteien
kontrolliert
in meinen augen ist das falsch man
sollte den bürgern viel mehr schritt um
schritt mehr freiheiten gewähren damit
diese wirklich ihre eigene meinung zum
ausdruck bringen kann
die ehemalige übergangspräsidentin
unterbricht das gespräch sie will kurz
raus an die frische luft bei der
bevölkerung die sz
daher ein hohes ansehen sie wirkte unter
anderem als professorin als
botschafterin und als außenministerin
sie hat ihr versprechen auch wert
durchgehalten und ist nach ablauf der
vereinbarten übergangszeit als
interimistische staatspräsidentin
abgetreten
für viele ist sie ein wichtiges symbol
die starke frau in der vor allem von
männern dominierten welt zentralasiens
möchten sie als frau die an vorderster
stelle in der politik gekämpft hat
beispiel sein für andere
zentralasiatische länder unbedingt
wir müssen uns von den vorurteilen
verabschieden
schauen sie unsere wichtigste
staatsanwältin zum beispiel ist eine
sehr schöne schlanke junge frau
dabei hatten alle erwartet als als
staatsanwalt ein dicker bei harter kerl
gewählt werden müssen
nein das muss nicht sein unsere neue
staatsanwälte ihn kennt alle gesetze sie
wird ihre arbeit äußerst professionell
durch man muss sich endlich von den
althergebrachten vorurteilen
verabschieden
ich bedanke mich will mich verabschieden
völlig überraschend ab lädt uns ruder
und tom beyer war noch zu sich nach
hause ein
das ist meine mutter meine mutter sie
liest gerne und so kommen wir nach der
offiziellen interview termin noch zu
einem brand in der küche gibt die
einstige übergangspräsidentin zu
erkennen wie wichtig ihr neben der
politik auch das private die familie ist
meine mutter hat sieben töchter und
einen sohn zur welt gebracht und sie
selbst haben sie auch kinder ja zwei
einen sohn und eine tochter
und ich habe auch einen enkel der ist
super
den warmherzigen besuch bei rosa
autobauer war werde ich wohl nie
vergessen
wir brechen auf in die berge von
bischkek nach cuzco und dann richtung
song können sie
wir sind
[Musik]
[Applaus]
80 prozent des landes sind gebirgigen
straße windet sich durch weitgehend und
berglandschaften
hinter den grasbewachsenen sanften
hügeln des landes sind bei regenwetter
die ganzjährig verschneiten gipfel zu
sehen
[Musik]
hier starten die auf seinem dreitägigen
pferde tracking seit tagen hatten wir
uns auf diesen teil der reise gefreut
es ist vor allem einem projekte
entwicklungsorganisation helvetas zu
verdanken dass die kirgisischen
bergbauern über diese tracks zu einer
engen zusammenarbeit untereinander
finden konnten mit den führungen und der
beherbergung von touristen kommen sie zu
einem wichtigen zusatzverdienst und los
geht's die pferde sind gutmütig
[Musik]
ein bisschen unheimlich ist mir aber
schon
anfänglich fürchte ich überraschend vom
sattel gekippt zu werden
doktor
[Musik]
[Applaus]
acht stunden sind wir an unserem ersten
treffen tag unterwegs und unsere york
der auf der alb klemke erreichen die
erst als es längst dunkel ist
[Musik]
tagesanbruch auf knapp 3000 metern höhe
jetzt lernen wir unsere freundliche
gastgeber familie beck bei tageslicht
können
[Musik]
hier gibt es keine straße kein auto kein
fließendes wasser und keine elektrizität
der alltag konzentriert sich auf die
tiere auf die natur um auf die beiden
einfach eingerichteten jurten eine der
orden ist für die gäste bestimmt die
andere für die familie und verwandte elf
personen leben in die vororte die
gleichzeitig als schlaf- wohn- und
essraum die das familienoberhaupt jemand
vater onkel und großvater versteht sich
in jeder beziehung als chef auf diese
art der mann ist das oberhaupt der
familie
so ist das bei den krisen seit uralten
zeiten er muss die familie beschützen
und für sie sorgen sowie dass der hengst
für seine stuten und fohlen macht der
mann hält die familie zusammen sagt was
gut oder schlecht ist für die familie
er regelt konflikte ich stehe jeden tag
um halb sechs auf und versuche so gut
wie möglich die verantwortung zu tragen
für alles für die familie schafe
ob der kleine rustam seinem großvater
nacheifern will
wir scherzen und russland
[Musik]
nach den kühlen werden nun die pferde
stuten gemolken damit die stute milch
gibt muss zuerst das fohlen angesetzt
werden
die kinder haben die diese jahreszeit
schulfrei und sie genießen es in ferien
beim onkel tante oder beim großvater
hier oben auf klänge zu verbringen
werbe milch erwirbt eine besonders
stärkende wirkung zugeschrieben
[Musik]
die goldzähne der zentralasiaten sie
sind symbol von reichtum ehefrau jenny
macht burgtor eine kleine aquila sie ist
fasziniert
die haben viele gäste aus europa und wir
sagen ihnen bitte respektiert unsere
kultur unsere tradition die natur die
wir erhalten
dieser rat gilt auch für die jungen
kirgisen in der stadt
die haben alles was sie wollen und
vergessen ihre eigene kultur und
tradition
[Musik]
allerdings der wunsch nach freier natur
ist nicht ganz ohne widerspruch gerne
nämlich hätte ja nil auch elektrisches
licht einen fernseher und mehr
radioprogramme immerhin ein freiluft
telefon gibt es hier schon
[Musik]
zusammen mit sara beck und unseren
jungen tracking für deutlich runter zum
flüsschen im tal der bauer zeigt mir was
eine orten jeweils stehen fünf
milliarden auf klemp noch schnee liegt
[Musik]
ein normales kind in rudow ich liebe
meine art zu leben
es ist ein freies land
ich kann den platz meiner juckte wenn
niemand mehr weg ich kann tun und lassen
was ich will oben bei den jurten die
großfamilie die älteren finden tagsüber
meist ausreichend zeit sich mit den
kindern oder enkelkindern zu
beschäftigen
reiten kann er jedenfalls schon da keine
rustam der mal präsident werden möchte
[Musik]
trotz der geruhsamen stimmung hier auf
klemmte wir verabschieden uns wir wollen
weiter über den 3400 meter hohen caracas
[Musik]
unsere pferde kennen die route trotzdem
man muss sie ab und zu
unmissverständlich am zügel führen damit
sie die weg spur nicht verlassen
[Musik]
von weitem sehen wir den song chol sie
den legendären kirgisischen gebirgssee
auf 3000 metern höhe
er ist etwa halb so groß wie der
bodensee
[Musik]
über sanfte gras weiten reiten wir zu
ihm handel
aha
mit unserem fahrer geht es nun wieder
weiter richtung chinesische grenze über
die stadt nahrung und dickeren stadt apa
she
auf der fahrt richtung toro guard pass
auf dem sich der grenzübergang nach
china befindet begegnen wir sozusagen
zwei welten zahlreichen
straßenbaustellen wellige modernisierung
symbolisieren
und dann immer wieder der tradition den
nomadentum jenen vergießen die vor allem
in und von der natur in jurten und von
der viehzucht legen
im auftrag der asiatischen
entwicklungsbank wird die ganze straße
von china bis zur hessischen hauptstadt
bishkek verbreitert und modernisiert
nicht ein klassisches unternehmen ein
chinesisches konsortium ein zuschlag für
diesen großauftrag erhalten
und zwischen dem tollen pass und naryn
arbeiten heute etwa fünf von der
chinesischen arbeiterinnen und arbeiter
unablässig an verschiedenen
streckenabschnitten zwölf stunden und
mehr am tag zum teil auch antworten
könnte
einer der leitenden ingenieure der apa
die sicherheit die arbeiten überwacht
ist nur langsam die kof ich habe gehört
dass die chinesen hier nicht nur die
straße aufbauen sondern auch eine neue
eisenbahnverbindung flüchten wollen
ja es gibt pläne für eine eisenbahn aber
unser staat hat kein geld
china will deshalb die bahn finanzieren
und möchte im ausgleich dafür der uns
rohstoffe abbauen
gold silber uran fürchten sie dass die
chinesen so ihre bodenschätze gründung
die machen das vorsichtig und ruhig ohne
krieg chinesin expandieren schritt um
schritt das verhältnis zwischen den
kassen und den chinesen ist nicht
spannungsfrei
die chinesen arbeiten und arbeiten
das unterscheidet sie von uns die
chinesen selbst nicht auch lernen
effizient zu arbeiten
ja aber wissen sie wir haben das im blut
wir essen gerne schlicks trinken kuh
muss unsere pferde milch lieben ein
ungezwungenes leben wollen nicht viel
arbeiten und wollen uns auf ein feld
schwingen und davon leiten
jetzt ruft der kinetischen bauführer
aber doch noch zu einer kurzen pause auf
da ich kein chinesisch spreche fruchtet
mein kontakt zu wenig
[Musik]
wir verabschieden uns von kirgistan
hessischen hat baschi führt diese
nördliche seitenstraßen route über den
tolo guard pass wenn die chinesische
stadt kashgar
[Musik]
die chinesische stadt kashgar liegt etwa
300 kilometer südwestlich des
grenzübergangs
ein blick über die stadt macht deutlich
dass hier zwei unterschiedliche kulturen
aufeinanderprallen jene der uiguren
gegen den einen zweistöckigen einfachen
leben häusern wohnen und jene der
zugewanderten han chinesen um den
modernen wohn und geschäftsvierteln
diese umweltfreundlichen und lautlosen
elektro roller haben meine
aufmerksamkeit geweckt und mich packt
die los mit einem solchen fletcher die
stadt im feierabendverkehr zu erkunden
[Musik]
ich fühle mich überraschend wohl im
chinesischen straßenverkehr
dies erscheint sich sehr viel
harmonischen weniger aggressiv zu
bewegen als der verkehr den ich von
unseren europäischen städten er kenne
[Musik]
ein blick gen chinesen viertel der stadt
ins moderne cash burn und zur 2000 jahre
alten altstadt die von der tour
sprachigen volksgruppe der uiguren
bewohnt wird nur wenige dieser
traditionellen lehm und backsteinhäuser
dürfen erhalten werden die meisten
dessen modernen bauten weichen
wenn sie aber irgendwie können versuchen
die uiguren ihre häuser zu renovieren
und erdbebensicher zu machen
[Musik]
und sie versuchen an ihre muslimisch
geprägten lebensweise festzuhalten
nein die chinesische regierung auch der
ziel tausende von han-chinesen in der
stadt ansiedeln werden die uiguren immer
mehr an den rand gedrängt diesen
uigurischen kupferschmied lässt man
demonstrativ gewehren auf als
touristenattraktionen
ich versuche mich an unserem dolmetscher
vorbei zu verständigen
die uiguren möchten mehr autonomierechte
päckchen aber will ihnen dieser nicht
gewähren
wie erlebt dass die regierung ist ihren
stein und wir sind wie ein ei kann
nichts gegen einen stein ausrichten wenn
die regierung was unbedingt will müssen
wir uns dem pflügen
ich will nicht dass sie mein haus
abreißen er möchte selbst renovieren
aber dazu fehlt ihnen das geld und wenn
er die staatliche unterstützung in
anspruch nimmt so werden seine
eigentumsrechte eingeschränkt wenn man
vom staat geld für die renovation nimmt
dann ist man nur noch mit besitzer
seines hauses 60 prozent gehören dann
dem staat und nur noch 40 prozent mir
selbst und die inneneinrichtung würde
nochmals sehr viel geld verschlingt das
können sich nicht alle leisten dass
unser gespräch von drei behördlichen
aufpassern überwacht wird die auf diesen
aufnahmen nicht zu sehen sind scheint
der branche schmid gelassen hinzunehmen
hier schießt ein neuer hoppe land
kongress komplex in die höhe
hier werden büro neue wohnhäuser für
chinesen gebaut die aus dem sogenannten
in china nach kaspar umgesiedelt werden
wir besuchen das baubüro der
immobilienfirma macht es wirklich sinn
die halbe stadt umzupflügen wir haben
hier schon jetzt 10.000 neue
arbeitsplätze geschaffen und solche
werden hier dringend benötigt es fehlt
aber auch ein großes einkaufszentrum mit
unserem großprojekt aus shanghai
versorgen hier kann's gar mit besseren
mit luxuriöseren angeboten china
verharrt zum teil zu sehr in primitiven
landwirtschaftsbereich unsere zukunft
darin liegt in der stadt so sieht es aus
wenn ich mit dem pressechef der
raumfähren markt zur baustelle unterwegs
bin
unsere dolmetscherin ist mit dabei aber
gleichzeitig werde ich auf schritt und
tritt von drei behördlichen aufpassen
begleitet
die zusammen
schon in ein paar wochen soll der
eingangsbereich dieses hat bell und
kongresszentrums fertig gestellt sein
[Musik]
dieses ligurischen lehmhäuser wurden
bereits geräumt unaufhaltsam wächst
kashgar in die höhe und unaufhaltsam
weicht der charme der alten oasenstadt
den frieden und kühlen baustilen aus
shanghai
[Musik]
ein paar kilometer außerhalb der 600.000
einwohner stadt
das ist mohamed ayadi er führt mit
seiner familien in kleinen hof und lebt
von einer bescheidenen vize
[Musik]
vielleicht dass das städtische in hoher
anzahl mich schmerzt es mit anzusehen
wie diese tiere verladen werden
[Musik]
muhammad ali macht sich mit seiner
ehefrau und seinem sohn auf den weg zum
sonntagsmarkt von kaschgar
[Musik]
von überall er treffe die händler auf
dem sonntagsmarkt 1
[Musik]
das verhandeln ist klar männersache
tiergerecht nach unserem verständnis
werden die schafe und ziegen ihr nicht
fest gebunden
das ist der preis für eine solche ziege
350 jana sind etwa 55 frank überall ganz
nach zentralasiatischer tradition wird
gehören und die geschäfte werden mit
einem freundlichen handschlag besiegelt
ich handle mit den tieren weil ich für
die landwirtschaft zu wenig guten boden
zur verfügung habe und so ergeht es
vielen uigurischen barum
es fehlt ihnen an lern sie stehen unter
druck wegen der stadt erweiterung
manchmal kaufe ich tiere dazu und lebe
dann vom wiederverkauf heute hat
muhammad ali aber nur ein paar tiere
verkaufen können
etwas frustriert fährt er nach hause
und wir erfahren von kafka den südlichen
rand der taklamakan wüste and land in
die trügerische stadt rothgang
babacan heißt so viel wie ort ohne
wiederkehr in dieser wüste ist es
außerordentlich heißen trocken hier
herrschen temperaturen zwischen 40 und
50 grad
wir trauen unseren augen nicht
zweiradfahrer erscheinen in der
gluthitze
[Musik]
woher kommen sie versuche ich es mal auf
englisch aus holland und sie sind den
ganzen weg von holland bis hierher
gefahren nein wir sind in kirgistan
gestartet und von dort nach kassel
fahren ein stück weit über den karakorum
highway und jetzt fahren wir nach
routern und was hat sie zu diesem
abenteuer motiviert ich habe meine
bisherige stelle gekündigt und habe ich
vor einen eigenen betrieb zu gründen
und jetzt bevor ich kinder habe wollte
ich diese chance packen und wir erklärt
die lokale bevölkerung auf sie das kommt
darauf an
die uiguren sind sehr freundlich die
sind ähnlich wie die menschen in
kirgistan tadschikistan chinesin
reagieren manchmal gar nicht wohl wegen
unserer kulturellen unterschiede
wenn man sich zu lächelt werden vieles
hier freundlich in kirgistan hat man uns
oft joghurt früchte oder brot gereicht
the practice 54
[Musik]
wir sind in roter der einen demütig
dargestellten figuren die hand reicht
symbol der chinesischen dominanz war
einst das bedeutendste zentrum der
seidenweberei hier in einem vorort
werden zeiten teppich nach
traditioneller art hergestellt und auf
der straße gewaschen
und hier hinter diesen mauern wert wie
in zahlreichen anderen jüdischen
familien betrieben so genannte applus
seite gefärbte stoffbahnen gewoben
handarbeit auf einrichtungen welche zum
teil von generation zu generation
weitergegeben werden
es sind ausschließlich männer die diese
arbeit tun und wir nutzen die chance
ihnen bei der arbeit zuzuschauen
durch das abdichten der seiten strenge
wird das künftige farbmuster vorgegeben
[Musik]
früher haben wir die raupen selbst
gezüchtet die fäden selbst gemacht heute
bekommen wir diese aus dem inneren china
zugeliefert aufgrund eines big rät der
chinesischen regierung wussten viele
maulbeerbäume die natürliche
lebensgrundlage der seidenraupen neuen
baumwollplantagen weichen und die
seidenraupen sie werden jetzt in
fabriken gezüchtet wir lieben unseren
beruf und geben unser wissen immer
wieder unseren kindern weiter die
seidenstoff produktion ist unsere
lebensgrundlage
[Musik]
nicht wo ich bin
die uiguren in dieser region leben in
ihrer eigenen welt parallel zur kulturen
zur wirtschaftsweise der chinesen
angesicht der expansion der chinesen ist
es für die muslimischen uiguren nicht
einfach an ihrer tradition und vor allem
an der besonderen art ihres
wirtschaftens festzuhalten
der vater von miley touré die genießt es
mit der großfamilie zu sein
wegen der sprachlichen barrieren können
wir uns zwar nicht unterhalten die
atmosphäre der familien idylle aber
spricht sich selbst blauen muster werden
im kalten bad aufgetragen
für die gelben ein verfahren werden die
seite strenge durch ein koch und heißes
bad geschwenkt
und schließlich werden die getrockneten
strenge verfeinerungen die jahre
gekommenen webmaschine zu zeigen bahnen
verwoben die typisch und tourismus vor
denen man fast überall auf das eigene
straße begegnet es ist abend und alle
versammeln sich im hof die ganze familie
stolz bringt uns meinte torri die abo
dollar
eine auswahl frisch gewos seidentücher
mir gefallen diese muster welche die
festtags der uiguren schmecken alles
selbst gemacht
von uns und ungarische frauen nähen
daraus ihre wunderschönen kleider
[Musik]
wir verlassen die familie und reisen
weiter in unserer nächsten folge liebe
ich die gewaltigen sanddünen von dünger
und eine form des massentourismus sehr
wohl nur in china möglich ist
wir sind dabei wenn ein teil der großen
chinesischen mauer restauriert werden
wir besuchen die stadt die weltberühmte
terrakotta-armee
das ziel von trassen straßen reise
[Musik]
[Applaus]